welcome to the spotted wing drosophila
webinar
for those of you who may not have done a
webinar before
i'm kathy heidenreich your host and our
speaker greg globe will be joining us
momentarily let me just give you a tour
of our classroom here
if you look up on the bar at the top of
the screen you'll see a little person
with their hand raised
if you hold down that bar you'll see
several options for you
to make a comment while the presentation
is going on
you can raise your hand agree or
disagree with the statement ask the
speaker to be louder or softer to go
faster or slower
show laughter or applause another way
you can participate is down in the chat
box at the bottom of the screen
you're able to type a comment or a
question hit the little conversation
bubble
and it pops up
just like that i also want to point out
some other features of the classroom to
you if you look over here
on the left you'll see there's a box
with related links
the cornell fruit website link is there
the pest management guidelines for berry
crops link is there and the berry
webinar
archive that berry webinar archive
is where this recorded webinar will be
so if you want to hear it again in the
future you'll be able to go to that link
and hear it it's going to be recorded i
see
james and jim have their hands raised do
they have a question already
if you do type it in the chat box good
job
okay over on the right you'll see that
there's
resource files for download and there's
a pdf that's a pdf of the presentation
that we're going to see shortly
and you're able to click on that and
it'll download to your computer and you
can print it so if you want to take
notes while you're listening you'll be
able to do that
okay before we start there's a couple of
housekeeping things we'd like to do we
have a couple of questions we'd like to
ask you
so we're going to have some polls show
up on the screen
and we'd ask that you'd uh please
respond to them some of those are for
record-keeping purposes
and some are to get a feel for who our
audience is
and how much background you may have on
spotted wing drosophila
so here's the first one very simple
are you a resident of new york state
everybody registered everybody voted
okay thank you very much we'll close
that one and go on to the next
could you please indicate your
occupation
and remember you're not obligated to
vote
but it's helpful for us if you tell us a
little bit about yourself in this way
okay everyone had a chance to vote
all right let's go on to the last one
how would you rate your knowledge of
spotted wing drosophila
okay
now the part you've all been waiting for
i want to introduce to you today dr greg
loeb
he's professor of grape and small fruit
entomology
at cornell university and greg received
his phd in entomology from the
university of california davis
in 1989 and began working at the geneva
campus of cornell and at the new york
state agricultural experiment station
in the department of entomology in 1995
as assistant professor
he has research and extension
responsibilities for grape and small
fruit crops
as i mentioned previously broadly
speaking his research expertise is in
applied insect ecology
and he's particularly interested in
plant insect interactions biological
control
and integrated pest management greg
good afternoon everyone and thank you
kathy for getting this all set up i know
it's
quite a bit of effort to kind of pull
all the different things together to
get one of these webinar webinars to run
seamlessly and it looks like it's
running pretty well right now
just it was interesting to look at the
poll and it's kind of what i figured i
think most of you
have some knowledge of spotted ring just
office some of you
are have quite a bit probably more than
i have in terms of
experience working with this insect and
some of you really are just learning a
bit
about it so the the way i uh
kind of oriented the talk was toward
people that don't know a lot about it
and then i'm hoping through questions
and comments we can kind of
expand upon some of this basic
information
that i want to cover i don't have a lot
of slides
i think there's 30 or so slides in this
so i don't think we're going to be
rushed for time so i really uh
look forward to uh any questions you
have or if you can
even have comments you want to add if
you can kind of put them in there in a
succinct way in the chat box that would
be great
uh kathy will hopefully uh keep
reminding me if i uh
don't see a a question come through to
to act on it because i figure
uh as much as possible we can and kind
of deal with questions as we go through
and then at the end if we have more
questions that that's great
as well uh kathy you can hear me okay
everything's great okay so um
i think i'll i think i'll head on in
then
looks like there's a little bit of a
chat going on in terms of uh
not being able to hear do you want me to
wait up a little bit kathy
um we'll we'll try to work on that in
the background
all right so i'm gonna move on in
um first thing i want to say is i really
want to acknowledge
a number of other people that are
contributed both to this talk and our
general
knowledge of spotted wing drosophila
this is an invasive insect that
wasn't originally it didn't show up
first in the northeast it showed up in
other states
and so some of my colleagues in these
other regions really have been doing the
the the initial work and i want to
particularly thank
rufus isaac that michigan state and
hannah barack at
north carolina state for the the work
they've been doing on that sort of
eastern united states and then
prior to that lots of people been
working on in the west for a couple
years
i also want to acknowledge that uh a lot
of the photographs i have i think all
the photographs i have basically
borrowing from
other people and i want to thank these
people and there might even be a few
more
that i've forgotten at this point to
include here
okay so the the outline i want to use
today oops i went a little too far here
um i want to cover sort of five areas
first off
i want to do a review fairly quickly of
the the history of sputtering drosophila
a little bit about basic biology life
history and
how to identify the adult stage anyhow
just kind of go over that
secondly i want to talk about what i
feel are the crops at most risk for
spotted wind drosophila
damage particularly in the eastern
united states and with a focus on the
northeast
monitoring is going to be important for
this pest during the invasion period and
colonizing period and maybe important
all the way throughout
our dealings with it so i'm going to
spend a little bit time talking about
how we're monitoring for adults and a
little bit for larvae
it's important to understand the
phenology of this insect i
i think it helps in terms of coming up
with management plans so i'll talk a
little bit about
what looks like the standard phenology
for uh
the timing of different life life stages
through the season
and finally i'll i'll finish up with
some
ideas on management
okay i'm going to head on then
hopefully we're going to get some of the
audio problems fixed as i go
now spider-man drosophila is originally
from the the asian area it has a fairly
wide distribution
in korea china japan uh in an asian
subcontinent
um it first showed up in uh north
america in california in 2008 and at
that time
um researchers asked okay
what is the potential distribution of of
this pest
based on where it's currently found in
its indigenous
area based on its climate you know
temperature requirements things like
that
and they came up with this projection
that highlighted the
the west coast of north america up into
canada
and a big area of the eastern united
states seem to be suitable
for this this invasive species to
become established so that was sort of
the prediction and projection in 2009
and that that time it was really only
known from the west coast and maybe they
had an
uh occurrence in florida
and right here is is the the the current
known distribution of of this pest and
it actually looks an awful lot like if i
go back
and look at that projected distribution
the known distribution as of now is
pretty similar to that
and it's probably still going to evolve
but it does indicate that the eastern
united states is going to be an area
of high colonization
and establishment so as i said it was
originally found in california
in 2008 affecting
several fruit crops i'll talk about that
in a second up into
the northern states washington oregon
and then into canada
showed up in florida fairly early but
it's never really built up too much of a
population in florida but has shown up
in other states in the in the south
michigan
uh got it in 2010 as did north carolina
where a lot of the work
research has gone on in 2011
it really exploded up into the
pennsylvania and up into the northeast
kind of invading showing up across that
region
and sometimes at really quite high
numbers and
everything looks like they're now
established in the northeast it's not
one of these sort of
one-time establishments that may
disappear i think
we're pretty much now in in the same
position as michigan
and out west where it's established and
something we're going to have to deal
with
okay the life cycle of this fruit fly
and it is a
it is like other fruit flies it it
has a fairly rapid development that's a
key important thing
we believe the the fruit fly over
winters as an adult
probably possibly the females over
winter better than than the males
we don't know a ton yet about
overwintering biology especially in the
colder climates
and something we need to learn more
about but these adults can live 20 or 30
days
maybe longer in the spring as
overwintered
mating and then laying eggs in
susceptible fruit
these eggs are inserted into the fruit
with the oil positive the female and
i'll show you a picture of that in a
second
and then often at the exterior surface
of the fruit you'll see these uh
breathing tubes uh white little fibers
out of the exterior that kind of
indicate an egg is
sitting underneath that after a
relatively short time these eggs hatch
into
maggots that feed on the on the fruit
directly
and develop over you know five to seven
day period
pupate either on the fruit in the fruit
or
dropping off of fruit and they pupate in
different places they sit in that purple
stage for a number of days
then emerge or reclose and repeat the
cycle
at the optimum temperature in that 70
degree fahrenheit
period they can go through this entire
cycle from the adult
to an egg laying adult in 12 days
so that's pretty quick so there's a
possibility of getting a number of
generations during the season and if
things are surviving well you have the
possibility of building up quite large
populations quickly
they seem to be somewhat limited by high
heat in the summer at least there's some
indications that they can't
tolerate very high heat
they may also be limited to some extent
by cold although
they appear to be surviving in some
pretty cold places
based on our information north america
and also based in in in work in japan
craig there's a comment from richard
cowell's that they've picked up one male
in connecticut about april 1st
okay so so richard uh
kohl's has mentioned that they've had
some trapping in connecticut and they've
picked up
a mail in april farooq
zamanet at long island i was going to
mention this a little bit later but
they've also been trapping through the
winter
and they started picking up i think they
were collecting a few
things in march and april both males and
females so it's maybe unclear how well
each of these sexes over winter but
clearly they're surviving um in these
areas
i'll come back to this a little bit
later but
they're already uh uh out and about and
presumably
if they're the adults are out if they
can find things to lay in
eggs into they're gonna be doing that so
one of the possibilities is that uh
they're already starting their cycles
they will take longer in the cool
weather
and the populations may not build up
really quickly and it will depend to
some extent how
how successful the adults were
particularly adult females
over wintering one of the things i don't
know and it may be known is whether
these females are mated in the
fall before they go into overwintering
and are ready to lay right away or they
need to mate
in the spring either way it's probably a
pretty quick process for them
okay identification and you're probably
pretty aware of this the identification
for purposes of monitoring are basically
you know based on the external
morphology of the adults
and you can both identify the male and
the female the male is the easier
uh sex to identify as its name
indicates that the the wing
on the forehead and and distal end of
that wing has a distinct spot
and it they're only a just maybe one
other two species that have spots on the
wings like that
um there's i know one species we were
catching
uh the males had double spots and
there's others perhaps out there that
occasionally show up that have a spot
but
if you find something with a spot like
this towards the distal leading edge of
that wing it's likely to be a male
spotted wing
in addition the the four leg
um has a these uh brushes on it that it
uses
and they kind of appear as two dark
bands and you can look at that
particularly under a scope or
a good hand lens and see that on the
males so the males are relatively
easy to identify females
don't have those nice markers on the
wings or or legs
what they do have is a very robust
ovipositor and that's
kind of shown on the right here where
they have these serrated uh
scleratorized structures and that they
use to
cut an insert position in the fruit in
order to lay their eggs
these things are quite a bit larger than
most of our other drosophilas
and they're a little bit hard to see uh
using just a hand lens but under the
scope and if you push on the the rear
end of the
abdomen you can get these uh opposites
to
um extend and it's quite quite
remarkable once you've seen a few of
them
um you kind of notice how much bigger
they are and more
robust they are than other species
practical purposes males are much easier
you don't really need a microscope to
identify
females really helpful to bring it in
and it will take a little bit of
practice to get used to identifying the
females
but it can be done but you really do
really helpful to have a scope for that
craig there's a question from donald
mclean he's wondering what the first
wild host fruit would be to watch at the
in the spring
ah that's a good question i'm trying to
think um
which ones would have right you know i
honestly don't top my hand
head no which ones might have fruit i
mean something like
i'm trying to think when the fruit of
dogwood might
show up or um another one is this um
oh what's it called i'm forgetting it's
a it's uh
olive in its name one that i'll come to
it a little bit oh autumn olive
autumn olive i i'm not exactly sure i
know those things are flowering
soon i mean autumn all this probably
flowering soon um
dogwood a little bit later hawthorne is
maybe a potential
some of those are going to be fruiting
but the fruit has to get ripe and i
honestly don't remember
when those are ripening i'm not sure how
important those are becau
but i do think we need to look at it it
depends on
sort of how high the populations are and
how much they exploit those things so
even things like wild strawberries
obviously going to get ripe
the earliest but how much they actually
get utilized by spotted wing i don't
know
that's the one that will be pretty early
but i think that's one of the questions
we need to get a better handle on terms
of which wild fruits are being used when
are they being used and how important
they are in terms of populations
okay there was a flurry of chat down
there so yeah
i see a note yeah is wondering about
service berry you talked about wild
strawberry
and uh eric is wondering about amelankir
richard cowell's commented they can also
breed in flowers and laura is wondering
if folks in long island and connecticut
are using vinegar traps
okay let me go uh so i don't know about
service berry that's a good question we
should look at it
the wild strawberry i was thinking of um
fregaria virginiana
i don't know about that the other one
in terms of potential fruit but it's
worth
looking at a lot of these things now
laura i believe
in long island they were using vinegar
traps i think that's true
in connecticut but i might have to ask
rich
about that as well rich
kohl's has made a comment that there's
evidence that they can also breed using
flowers in flowers so that's interesting
as well taking advantage of the sweet
areas in there
i see another question this is great
keep them coming can they use compost
piles for breeding
well that is a good question if if the
compost piles are not
exceedingly hot it's possible that
flies could breed in there whether there
was some rotten fruits and things like
that they could utilize i suspect
it's possible unless you know if the
composting isn't really
done well in terms of getting that heat
up my guess is the heat would kill it
um farooq said and confirmed that indeed
in long island they've been using uh
apple cider vinegar
for their kind of season long or
year-long sampling
hopefully i addressed as best i could
the the questions but some of these i
just actually don't know the answer
particularly the wild host i really hope
to learn a lot more about
potential wild hosts concurrently works
going on in michigan
in new jersey uh and i presume uh
uh other states looking at wild hosts
because i think
none of us the researchers believe this
might play an important
part in the phenology and population
dynamics of this pest
okay i'll move on
at least temporarily we can always come
back to some of these questions uh
and talk a little bit about what you
know
commercial agricultural crops are
probably at greatest risk
from sputtering drosophila and let's say
the northeast as well focus
in on so i just have a table of
potential hosts
and first thing is to look at the high
risk crops for our areas
i think evidence is indicating that
raspberries
and the cane berries in general but
particularly the fall maturing ripening
raspberries
are particularly vulnerable blackberries
late
maturing blueberries day neutral
strawberries
again when day neutrals often we get
fruit in the spring and then
again in the late summer and fall and
it's the late summer and fall
strawberries that seem to be quite at
risk they seem to be quietly highly
preferred
sweet cherries also are utilized
that's been a big problem on the west
coast whether it's as big a problem here
on the
on the east is still not clear but
certainly potential risk there
that's kind of where they first really
had ran into problems with us wasn't
sweet cherries
um but maybe that
for us in the wa the the eastest these
fall raspberries are going to be our
our most important one in terms of
moderate risk a number of fruit
crops are possibly uh to be exploited
one is grapes we often get questions
about and i think we have a big question
mark around grapes
spotted wing softly can develop in
grapes
will lay their eggs in grapes but they
don't seem to be highly preferred
crop unless there's already some damage
in there and our observations this
really comes from
rich cole's work in connecticut in 2011
grapes late in the season were actually
hit pretty hard by spottoing drosophila
now
2011 was a tough year for vinifera type
grapes that were
ripening late in the season we had bad
weather hurricanes things like that
so that the fruit itself was in bad
shape and that may have
exacerbated fruit fly damage in general
including
fruit flies coming out of or excuse me
including spider-wing drosophila some
work out of
california some researchers out there
have indicated that if the grapes are in
good shape and intact
sputtering is not as likely to try to
lay eggs in it or and it's not as prefer
to host
east coast situation our our weather is
different
our conditions are likely to be
different so i think it's an open
question on the risk of grapes
and i think that's something we're going
to have to look at as well as some of
these other crops we're just going to
take some time to to figure this out
under moderate risk or even slight risk
i'm going to add now
june bearing strawberries now i say this
because
for a number of years when researchers
for the last couple years anyhow
researchers have been looking
in both june bearing strawberries and
day neutral strawberries and have found
no evidence
of egg laying in june bearing
strawberries they seem to be maturing
before
really the populations have built up to
an extent that they're causing a problem
a noticeable problem in 2012
in the southeast we now have reports of
larvae being collected from june bearing
strawberries now this is out of a
researcher's
field was not being picked very clean so
it was a lot of ripe and overripe fruit
in that field
and it wasn't very high numbers it was
only a
a a couple of maggots in a few fruits
but
it suggests the potential is there and
something we're going to want to look at
over time to see if june bearing
strawberries are at risk for either
economic damage
or potentially simply acting as at a low
level a
reservoir for these um overwintered
spotter wing software to get their
generations going and building up
let's say even on the residue of
june bearing strawberries and providing
the sort of the next step
as they move towards the late season and
build up to higher populations on things
like blueberries
and uh summer and fall raspberries
craig there's a question from jonathan
about how early they've been laying eggs
i'm going to show you a little data here
just in a second but it
it looks like the fruit needs to be
pretty ripe before they really start
laying eggs into it
so that you're not likely much at risk
with green fruit
and even fruit that's changing color
and getting ripe probably pretty low
it's really as they get ripe
and susan is asking a question about
these compared to
the regular household fruit fly so
we have several species of fruit flies a
common one in fruit
is the kind of fruit fly of genetics
fame
drosophila melanogaster and it typically
in is only getting into fruit that it's
over ripe and
really almost rotten and in fact they
utilize um
symbionic uh yeasts and things that they
actually feed on that really don't get
going until the fruits
very very ripe so i think uh
melanogaster can be our nuisance it
certainly shows up in our houses we get
them in wineries
and and can be a problem but you know
unless the fruits being damaged by other
things those other fruit flies
aren't as big a deal this fruit fly is i
think a much
much greater concern because it's going
into ripe
marketable fruit so that there's a real
chance
if the populations are high and you're
not controlling them of
growers selling fruit with maggots in it
eggs and maggots inside
that look pretty normal but look really
decent so that they're willing to sell
them
and that's the real real risk from this
this pest
and why there's so much interest in
figuring out ways of
managing it and understanding its
biology and managing it so yeah this
this thing's quite different and it all
comes down to that
big overpositioner that they have that
are able to get into
and tack fruit bernice wondering if
early and mid-season blueberries are at
risk um i think over time they may
become at risk
right now the information suggests that
um
they're not uh as likely and it's the
later
season varieties where they're finding
it potentially now
in blueberries it's a little hard to
tell in terms of commercial blueberries
because
they may be spraying for other things
like um in in our area
anyhow for blueberry maggot
and the same materials that are they're
using against blue and magnet may be
killing and likely killing uh spottoing
drosophila so
you know the we'll need some more
information on sort of unprotected
blueberries and that kind of thing to
sort of figure out
uh which varieties at most risk again
i'm suggesting the later season are
probably the greatest risk but
over time it's not inconceivable that
as these flies show up earlier in the
early season that other crops
or other earlier maturing varieties are
at risk
i'm going to look over the questions
here because they're coming in which is
great
hans has indicated
where to go that he assumes thin-skinned
grape varieties are more at risk
like pinot noir or many of the nifra
than thicker skin hybrids and native
grapes
um it's that's probably true hans uh and
but um i don't i'm not aware of any
specific data that's tested
uh and shown a big difference i think
most of the work i've seen has been
mostly on vinifera though out in out of
oregon
but there may be some more information
out there i'm not aware of that i need
to look at but
it's a reasonable assumption as well is
a lot of our native hybrid grapes
especially native grapes are not going
to be as affected by the the fruit rots
and things like that so they're going to
be in better
shape and not have these injuries
rich kohl's noted and something i meant
to mention
is that some things he's observed both
in the lab and in the field is that
color
can be quite important in terms of
attractiveness to these adult flies and
from a position so that
dark colors red colors or dark colors
what they probably see
may be important so that dark colored
grapes may be more attractive to these
flies than light colored
grapes so some of our red varieties the
pinot noirs the cabernets the merlots
and potentially the conquered grapes may
be
more susceptible and it's again
something that we'll need to look at
yeah okay um what i get a question from
carol enton what about fruit sitting in
open baskets at a farm stand would this
attract old pausing females and
customers
could be going home with eggs and larvae
and fruit
sure i would expect it's very clear that
these fruit flies use odors associated
with ripe
fruit and if you had a basket sitting
out there just like
other fruit flies you might get spotted
wings attracted to those
and it's potential they could lay eggs
whether those eggs would actually
hatch you know if they were taking home
put in the refrigerator and
and and not in you know or consumed
right away whether that would really be
a huge issue in terms of the eggs
it would take a few you know some time
for those eggs to hatch and it would
need to leave their fruit sitting out
so i'm not sure you know whether a lot
of that would come back to haunt you
but it's at least something to be uh
somewhat aware of
and i don't know whether you might you
know it would be something we want to
look at i know there's ways to put
netting over these things
that would be a dragon away because you
want your customers to be able to see
the fruit
and and choose it and i would have to
think about that as
a potential risk i guess i initially i
would say
not a huge risk at least in terms of
getting maggots possibly eggs
that's a good question though
um let's see yes i'm just confirming
that yeah the
the real danger as a
in terms of uh marketing and economic
damage is
selling fruit with maggots in it
okay um wild host i
already could have talked about that and
i think we need to learn a lot more i
just list some of the ones that rufus
isaacs and michigan state has been uh
looking at and we're going to start
looking at a number of these
this year um in in
in close proximity to some of our small
fruit crops
um and that raised submission questions
you know that i think one of our other
people were getting at
could we possibly use one of these
alternate wild hosts as
a indicator plant
to kind of help warn us of a potential
uh
risk from the spotted ring egg lane in
our in our cash crop
and that that would be really quite
helpful
i will talk about monitoring more later
but one of the things we have found is
that
the the traps as we have them right now
for catching adults often
only get adults after some egg laying
has occurred in the crop
so it's kind of a delayed signal and it
would be nice to have a signal that says
okay
there's a lot of those fruit flies or
some fruit flies in the area
and you know we need to really increase
our vigilance at this time so that's one
of the reasons we're quite interested in
the alternate hosts
i'm looking at a couple of questions
here um eric
security says any skin damage will
damage keeping quality so old position
is an economic concern in terms of uh
rot during shipping oh that's a good
point eric thanks
um so that's another
aspect of the damage so the puncturing
of the skin
could easily that's a good point if
there's any kind of surface fungi or
act actually we know these these uh
flies are probably carrying bacteria
and and fungus on their obaposter so
that's a good point
in terms of you get some egg laying that
would shorten your shipping and storage
and that would be a drag
kate gilbert asked if they are attracted
dark colors would be attracted to
something like traps using
grape jelly um
yeah that's a good possibility they are
attracted certainly to
apple cider vinegar and they're
attracted to wine
so some fermented grape juice they're
attracted to
uh bread dough that's started to ferment
a little bit this is a
work that rich kohl's discovered uh last
year
so a lot of these aromas associated with
fruit and even
fermenting fruit uh seem to be
attractive um
whether grape jelly uh uh would be uh
the right thing i mean hopefully we're
gonna come up with a other
lures that are a little more compact and
easy to use but
i think again that's going to be an
active area of research in terms of
what makes the best lure that can get
these
insects into traps for monitoring
purposes or
hopefully down the road something really
attractive that we could use in
an attracting kill station as a way to
reduce the populations
using an insecticide but not having to
apply that insecticide on the crop
see elaine do we know uh what spray to
use when we should spray yeah
elaine i'm going to come to that towards
the end of the talk and there are some
insecticides that actually are pretty
effective against the adults
there's some some issues related with
that but i will come to that uh
at the end of the talk thanks
um carol asks carol bragg asks should
vinegar traps be made with dark colored
containers
um and again i'll talk about that
in a little bit in terms of monitoring
but um
it does appear perhaps that red colored
uh or dark colored traps may be a little
more attractive although
it hasn't been a huge difference between
that and
clear clear containers in terms of the
traps
but it doesn't hurt perhaps to have dark
colors i think more important is making
sure that you have
a lot of places where the aromas are
able to escape out of the trap
and that the flies will be able to
detect from a distance and come in and i
think that's
a quite important trait and also placing
the trap
in in a the correct position
to optimize captures
um and again i'll say this again later
but coming up with something more
attractive than apple cider vinegar
would be nice and there is work going on
there and i'm hopeful that we're going
to come up with something that's
actually a little bit better
those are excellent traps now i wanted
to talk a little bit more about what
makes
a fruit more susceptible and i wanted to
show you a little bit of data from
jana lee who's entomologist works for
the usda ars
in oregon and she looked at blueberries
at different ripeness and
assessed egg laying and larvae in that
fruit so she looked at green fruit
green to pink and then blue fruit and
you can see from this
graph let's see if i can find my pointer
i don't know where it went
whoops i turned it off okay so you can
see from this graph on
from terms of eggs laid not very many
eggs and green fruit she did get a
little bit
but this is hearing kind of ex
enclosures where the
the the the fly doesn't have a lot of
choices
and so it would lay a few but the vast
majority
of eggs were laid in ripening to ripe
fruit
in these blueberries in terms of that
ones that developed into
larvae two weeks later again it was the
ripest fruit that
resulted in larvae
a hannah barack and her grad student
looked this in a similar kind of
question about this
idea of ripening and uh
thickness and toughness of the skin and
they looked at uh blackberries
blueberries raspberries and strawberries
different varieties
um that had different uh puncture
strengths so
uh different levels of toughness so the
higher this value the tougher the
the skin of that fruit and over on the
the y
excuse me x axis number of eggs laid in
20 grams of fruit and as you can see as
toughness decreases you
get many more eggs for these different
crops with uh raspberry you know being
the
the
some of the thinnest easiest punctured
fruit
getting the most eggs but that was
similar to
strawberries and blueberries and
blackberries so that again
shows that it's probably skin toughness
skin thickness is
a pretty important factor and it also
suggests
the possibility maybe hans was getting
at this with his question
that in terms of breeding for resistance
this might be one trait that can be
exploited
to to reduce the egg lane i mean there's
going to be trade-offs associated with
toughness uh of the skin that will have
to come into play here but that's at
least one potential avenue that
researchers and breeders can uh pursue
okay let's um talk a lot more about
monitoring because i think of the
situation that many of us
us are in where the pest hasn't been
here very long
we really don't know when they show up
where they show up
which fruits are greatest at risk which
farms are at greatest risk
we need a way to kind of assess the
presence of these things
for right now management of them when
you get them is
primarily based on insecticides i mean
we want to find some other approaches
but insecticides are key
and key to that and key to being able to
continue to market
your fruit is detecting the presence of
these flies and starting some sort of
control program in response some
chemical controls program so monitoring
is quite
important we believe
i just got a quick look at a question
here from donald
mclean for quick trap counts can one
assume that if number flies a
a cot if the number of flies
are caught and several our males are
other let me read this more slowly i'm
not getting it all
all right for quick drop counts can one
assume that if a
number flies are caught several are
males and
are others likely females okay yeah so
what's the relationship between
the males that you can see when you just
are looking with the hand lens or just
your naked eye and number of females
rufus isaac that michigan did some work
on this and at least
during the season there's a pretty good
50 50
relationship so if you're getting you
know five or ten
males on that uh on that uh trap
you're probably also getting five or ten
females there is some suggestion that
the females might show up a little bit
earlier than the males at the
the onset of a uh colonization
and infestation period so that it's
possible by only looking for males you
might miss the initial start of that but
i think this is something we need
a little bit more data on
okay so monitoring for spotted wing
adults
and that's kind of where our focus has
been mainly on i mean you could
potentially also monitor a
larvae in the fruit but what you want is
an early detection before you get
larvae or as soon as you can
before you actually start getting
infestation to detect that the
the adult spider wing is present so
researchers have been trying a number of
different approaches what seems to be a
consensus approach that works pretty
well
is using a cup trap it can vary in size
we've been using 32 fluid ounce deli
cups made out of polypropylene which are
pretty
strong flexible material last a long
time
ours have been we've been using clear
and being successful
although as i mentioned earlier darker
colors red colors maybe a little bit
better you don't need we use 32 ounces i
think that's
overkill the lures that we've been using
so far have been apple cider vinegar uh
a couple inches of that
um plus a little bit of unscented soap
to reduce the soup the surface tension
on the surface so you can collect the
adults at the top
of the container of course we have a a
solid
lid that keeps the rain out but along
the upper
top of the container we have drilled
holes
about 12 of these holes at four or five
millimeter diameter
around the top that are used to both
release the aromas of the the lure in
this case the apple cider vinegar
and also let the flies get in there
and you'll of course get other things in
there besides uh
spotted wing drosophila you'll get other
species of drosophila
and other insects that can fit into that
hole that it might be attracted to the
the aromas so you'll and these things
will kind of come in here maybe fly
around a bit
and they get into the the vinegar and
die
i have a couple inches of vinegar as i
said at the bottom of the trap
these traps should be hung as possible
as much as possible in the shade
um when we're putting these in in trees
and on
raspberries that have trellises in
vineyards with trellis wires we've been
in blueberries on branches we've been
using what we've been using are these
wire
hangers that we get from pheromone traps
and shaping a sort of a circular
area one end and just putting the trap
down
and so it holds the trap and then
attaching the other end of the wire to a
branch or something
for something like strawberries we're
going to work with a steak of some sort
and have some sort of strapping around
that steak to put the
the the trap closer to the canopy of the
of the strawberries near where the fruit
is to
i think that's a better place in terms
of attracting the flies
um i just saw a quick question uh from
susan saying
susan selby asking uh whether apple
cider vinegar
is for color and can we add red food dye
um
the apple cider vinegar is really for
the aroma that seems to be
attractive to them uh to these flies at
a distance um
the the apple cider is pretty dark
colored it's probably dark enough
we haven't tried darkening it with a
a food ad you know some sort of dye but
that's an interesting idea that
perhaps we'll have some other ins more
insights on later in the season
um oh i also see that farooq mentioned
earlier back when i was talking about
sex ratio and
how representative the males are to the
females he was saying during the middle
season they were getting 50 50 males and
females in their traps on long island
that's pretty much what we were seeing
in our traps in the finger lakes and i
think rufus was finding similar
levels again early in the season the
earliest season it's possible there's a
bias towards females
something we need to learn more about
what kind of soap bernie smith was
asking what kind of soap i think
any kind of laundry not long detergent
dishwater detergent that's unscented is
what we can use
and just just need a drop of it in there
and in fact it's i'm not even
sure it's super necessary that's just
been generally the recommendation
oh i get a note here from richard uh
cole's
commenting that colored trap liquid can
interfere with being able to see
spots uh in the wings
that's a good point so if you end up
dying the fly you might make it more
difficult to identify thanks richard i
that's a good it's a good point
something that you certainly would want
to look at as you were asking these
questions
um okay you've got these traps out there
we've been
most people been trying to to visit them
once a week
you filter the vinegar through some sort
of filter system to collect
uh all the insects that are in there
and we've been filtering the vinegar
into an old vinegar apple vinegar jar
to collect it so we can dispose of it
elsewhere rather than just throwing it
out nearby
and you know it's unclear whether if you
threw out the vinegar nearby whether it
would become a source of attraction to
the fly so they no longer be attracted
to the trap that's the reason
to discard it away from where you're
trying to monitor
whether that's actually been tested or
not i'm not sure but it seems like a
reasonable precaution to take
so you would filter these flies you what
we do anyhow is we use um
coffee filters that we in a coffee
and a you know some sort of sieve that
we put the filter in
so we pour the apple cider vinegar
through that collect the the residue
i've labeled that paper copy filter with
the trap number
i generally bring these back to the lab
and let them dry out for a little bit so
they're not totally wet and then
scan the individuals for
uh sputtering drosophila and in my case
we have
scope so so that we would look under the
scope for
females to identify both males and
females
of spotted wing plus other species and i
want to emphasize that
you're likely to catch other fruit fly
species so you need to go through that
step of at least identifying the males
um so you replace that vinegar weekly
apparently
over time the attractiveness of vinegar
does decrease so
again it's important to replace that
lure uh
regularly um and as mentioned uh
the last point here is that it's
generally you start detecting these
adults as fruit is ripening or is ripe
um and i also as i mentioned the results
from the west and
and in the east is it's not uncommon to
not catch your first adult until after
you've
got evidence of egg laying
so that uh
it's not an ideal trap for an early
warning it's just a point i
made earlier and we're very interested
in developing
a more attractive lures um i am working
with a peter landault uh ars scientist
out in
in washington who's been doing some work
on synthetic lures
and in fact uh hopefully uh i and some
other of us will be testing some of
their synthetic lures this year
to see if we can get improvement over
apple cider vinegar
now some of you might be familiar with a
work that's been done both in california
and michigan
and oregon on a different lure based on
yeast and water and sugar so basically
you're creating this
yeasty fermented mix and using that
instead of apple cider vinegar and
there's some
discrepancies in the results from the
different areas in michigan
these yeast based lures although they're
a mess to use have been
a little bit better in the beginning of
the the season i believe i remember this
correctly at um
catching flies this wasn't what hannah
barack found in north carolina so
um it's sort of unclear how much benefit
you get from using this these sort of uh
uh fermented uh yeast uh solutions as
lures i think we need more work on that
um hopefully we'll come up with a
synthetic
lure that we can put in a rubber septa
or something like that or in a small
polypropylene vial that we can use as a
an attractant rather than have to deal
with all this but we're not there yet
and more work is needed but so but my
point about this
yeasty uh lure is that that may provide
some benefits although it's a real a
mess to work with
in trying to sort out and get the flies
out um
i see a question here from donald mclean
uh mentioning that their experience in
fall raspberries
that if they checked their
traps on a daily basis this resulted in
increased uh
catches um suggesting that and i assume
he means that they refresh their vinegar
each
each day kind of maybe emphasizing
that uh the freshness of the vinegar is
important one of the things i don't know
and i'm not sure it's been done
is exactly kind of what uh donald's
talking about is looking at a
decay curve like how attractive is one
day two days three days four days five
days
and looking at sort of what you're
losing by waiting a week
certainly for uh the widespread
monitoring it would be pretty difficult
to
change on a daily basis but for a grower
on a couple different sites you know
that's that's very possible so that's an
interesting point that
it's worth looking at uh susan
said mention that so the traps i'm sorry
let me read this
if the traps get out early then if
they're in the area before our fruit
ripens
they are attracted to and caught in are
they still attracted to and cotton traps
so in other words if we put these
attractant lures out in
raspberry before they have ripe fruit or
you're likely to catch anything
i think the experience has been not
really um
maybe occasionally but uh i think the
experience has been that work better
when uh when they're near
fruit that's ripening i don't know maybe
other people have a comment on that
because i'm not really sure
greg i i'm wondering if you put your
traps out
or this is kathy if you put your traps
out before the fruit is ripe are you
actually drawing
them to the planting are you shooting
yourself in the foot
is what i'm wondering so in other words
uh
bringing them in and then they just move
over to your fruit
yes given how rare it is to catch them
before the fruit is ripe
i i kind of doubt that but you know it's
conceivable
um i would think though that we would be
catching them in there before
ripe fruit and then they would maybe
move over to ripe fruit i know in straw
with strawberry sap beetle
we sort of see that if we put out bread
dough in a strawberry field before we
have ripe strawberries we'll catch a lot
of sap beetle
but as soon as the strawberry's ripe we
stop catching them
to nearly the extent um
into yeah nearly to the extent uh that
we do before there's ripe strawberry
fruit
uh and i think possibly the same
principle would occur here
for spotted wing um i wanted to
highlight a comment that richard uh
cole's put through that i was going to
mention at the end as well
is that it is conceivable it's something
that we want to look at
um in the future uh and richard's really
taking the lead on this
is possibly trying to mass trap out the
population of flies
at a site let's say you're a raspberry
grower
after the raspberries are gone the flies
are still around
can you collect and kill by using these
traps that are attractive
and basically greatly reducing your
overwintering population so you don't
have as big a problem
the next year it's a it's a hypothesis
at this point but something that
might be possible and if you can find
the attractive lure
and even vinegar might apple cider
vinegar might work at that time of year
you might be able to have an effect and
that's something we
would definitely want to look at
all right here's a good question from
carol um how large an area can one trap
cover how closely should they
be spaced um again we don't
have real clear date on that we're
tending to
put one or two traps in a even a as big
as a five acre
probably two traps in a five acre
planting
if you're only going to put a few traps
out i would recommend putting them out
on the edge of your planting
there's some evidence that you know the
flies are coming in from the edge and
you're more likely to catch them
at the edge first
and
uh you know whether you would benefit
from having 10 traps out there
it's hard to know so i've got two to
four per
a five acre planting would probably be
sufficient um to detect their presence
although they don't have specific data
on that
and how close they should be spaced um
i'm using something like again i don't
have specific
data you want to have you know i'm going
with
10 to 20 20 meters apart for our traps
and when we're putting multiple traps in
a field just so they're not
kind of competing with each other
but again we haven't done the experiment
to kind of test what that optimal
sphere of influence is for a particular
lure
carol s is trapping for monitoring and
not yeah i'm sorry i didn't see that
yeah
so so trapping is primarily at this
point for monitoring not for protecting
the crop
so you know we we've used uh mass
attraction and kill for some other pests
successfully in some conditions even for
uh something like a blueberry maggot
in small plantings we've been able to
use a attractive things at the periphery
and be able to actually reduce the
overall population and
is something like that possible for
sputtering drosophila i think
it's possible it depends on how far they
disperse
from other areas and things like that
and getting a really attractive lure put
out at the right place
and that comes back to something rich
rich was suggesting
is in attract and kill kind of uh
bait station
um don donnell asked will spider-wing
softly be moving over distances
as last year region to region and that
is a good question
i am guessing that the populations are
going to build up
in the south like they did in the
previous years in north carolina georgia
up into virginia
and in the right kind of climate
situation whether the right kind of
storm front is coming up
sure some spotted wing maybe even a lot
of spoddling can be
redistributed through these storm fronts
we don't have a lot of data on that but
it certainly
makes sense and it fits the pattern we
saw last year
after some of those big storms came
through in the fall and all of a sudden
we had spotted wing everywhere
and i think that's a really good
question so and i don't think we
completely test it so last year
they just exploded and showed up
everywhere through all the way up into
maine
and and beyond and they seem to be
corresponding with these storms
to some extent how well will they
survive in these
more northern populations i don't know
in this winter probably
okay may if it was a normally cold
winter maybe not so much
so i think it's going to maybe vary and
depend on the year
how important the dispersal is from the
south
versus the population growth from our
the populations that overwinter as a
good question and one i guess i
we really don't know the answer to but i
i
wouldn't be surprised if long distance
movement from the south is not
part of the dynamic for this pest much
the same way
that it is for something like potato
leaf hopper and we may find that certain
regions are more vulnerable to
where these storms drop them off than
others that would be something that we
want
to get a handle on
okay and the question is do we know how
far adults travel
and there's sort of two types of travel
they might be doing
something that the entomologists call
trivial dispersal and that's sort of
local movement
you know from this raspberry field over
to uh this other raspberry field or to
the farm next door
and we don't have a lot of information
yet on
their sort of daily movement they
clearly can move you know meters
tens of meters are they moving
kilometers
i doubt it um on a day certainly on a
daily basis
there is work going on in california and
oregon
using mark release recapture techniques
or mark and recapture techniques to try
to start getting an estimate of this for
example
looking at the distance movement from
fruit flies that are coming from wild
blackberry in this case in the in the
study in oregon that i'm thinking about
they're marking those flies as they're
emerging
out of that that wild crop where they
think it's an important source
and then looking for these marked flies
in different areas at different
distances so we will be able to start
getting a handle on
what we are calling sort of local or
trivial dispersal
now there's long distance dispersal the
type that i think we did see last year
on these storm fronts and and those can
be quite long obviously
how often that occurs and how many of
them travel that way
we don't know and something we're going
to perhaps want to get a better handle
on
but from sort of on a farm basis we
don't yet know i think they're
mobile but how mobile i'm not sure
um i get a question here what areas of
new york have
they been seen in um from elaine and
i'll come to that in a second but then
in eastern parts of new york is in
central new york is where we've seen the
most of it and i'll show you
um some data on that in a little bit uh
bernie smith asks so on a farm with a
lot of woods
and a lot of wild grapes etc are you
saying traps will help
i guess what i'm thinking about in terms
of wild hosts
near near a farm that traps in those
wild hosts that they may be an early
warning system
that that the crop plants are at risk
not necessarily that traps would help
kind of eliminate them like a mass
trapping but that
that might be a place where you might be
able to use and that the adults would be
captured
sooner than they would in let's say your
raspberries your fall raspberries and
you could
use that as a early warning that okay i
need to be
doing something with my raspberries
um another question well let me finish
up on this uh
cathy um related to that one question
you might ask as well if
these wild hosts are really important or
a certain couple species are really
important and the flies don't travel
very far
does it make sense to try to remove some
of these wild hosts
and that's a good question i'm a little
bit doubtful of that but it's something
we need to think about
uh if we especially we could find that
certain wild hosts are particularly
um attractive to the flies and there's
not so many of them that
they're not it's not impossible to
basically remove
and that the flies aren't moving so far
that
your effort right next to your farm is
being overwhelmed by
things you can't control uh hopefully
that made sense
kathy yes i i just wanted to comment
uh greg that we're already at two
o'clock and if we could just hold
some of the questions so that we can get
through the um
rest of the presentation there'll be
time for discussion at the end
okay so feel free to put your questions
in the chat box but let's let's continue
through the presentation and we'll get
to them at the end
all right all right fair enough i my
last question was
bernie's on uh wild close plants around
the wood edges
i want to mention that it is possible to
look for the larvae or
even the the egg presence of eggs on the
surface of the
the fruit with a hand lens
and for small plantings or well not just
small plantings but you may be able to
get a sense of it
for some fruit it's not very obvious
that there's egg laying going on unless
you look pretty closely
so you can see here some pictures that
i'm not sure actually uh me rufus sent
me with some of these
um on blueberry both the puncture holes
and then the the breathing tubes with a
hand lens
and a good light you can you can see
this
you can also um look in the fruit for
the the larvae
we can use something called a flotation
technique where you take a collection of
ripe and overripe fruit
maybe mash it up a little bit and then
pour salt water
on it at that ratio of one tablespoon of
salt per one cup of water
and in in that condition the larvae tend
to float up
to the top now you can't tell if that's
a spot a wing
uh drosophila larva or a another species
of fruit fly but at least tell you that
you've got some infestation going on
here
and that can be useful for some crops
let's say for fall raspberry if you
detect some
larvae okay you don't want to sell
what's currently on the planting you can
do a real
clean picking put in your control
measures
and then anything ripening beyond that
should be well protected
so that can be be helpful technique
and we'll be doing some of this in
conjunction with rearing outflies this
summer
okay a brief mention of phenology i've
kind of alluded to this
um a number of times like when do these
flies really build up populations
during a season what's their seasonal
dynamics
and this results from a a unmanaged
blueberry field in
michigan provides what the general
pattern has been for the bulk of the
population
so this is a field rufus was monitoring
with the with his traps
using apple cider vinegar in these traps
and
they monitored throughout the season and
maybe they caught their first
first adult in early july but
populations really didn't start taking
off
until late august into september
and into october so presumably
those fruits that are ripening at that
time
particularly fall raspberries late
season blueberries
potentially grapes if they're vulnerable
are the ones
and and day neutral strawberries would
be out here as well
those are the ones that we think are
going to be the most at risk because of
this general pattern
that we see of populations really only
building up to
huge numbers late in the season and this
is something we've seen in the east and
they also see in the west
when they show up is a little bit
earlier in the more mild climates or
where the flies have been around longer
i think rufus is starting to see flies
initial catches a little bit earlier i
think hannah and
north carolina see them a little earlier
each year
so we may see some of that but really
the big populations are building up late
in the season
and hence why the fruits that i've
identified i think are those the ones
we're going to be at most at risk and in
practice have been
now real briefly um for new york i
wanted to mention what we did last year
we
a number of us initiated monitoring
spotted wing during the
the season last year um farook
zahman and dan gilring started putting
traps out in september in long island
um of 2011 peter and laura
were looking for him in later season in
raspberries uh
in hudson valley i think farooq and dan
were looking a number different crops
in the finger lakes uh we were looking
at a number of different crops and we
actually monitored using these adult
traps
throughout the season and tim weigel was
looking in grapes
their first collection this is the first
capture known in new york they may have
been here earlier but the first one we
got
was in the end of august uh peter found
this in hudson valley
i believe actually in a vineyard
remember this their adults though
most of our captures though were in
september october and then
onward and in fact in long island
farook i didn't have all the state of
the show farooq got some incredible
numbers
of traps late late season on on long
island
um so they were just they were showing
up in hudson valley
long island eastern new york in general
but also the the
finger lakes tim weigel did not get any
detections in western new york but he
mainly only sampled in vineyards
there was some detections in north
northwest pennsylvania
um actually excuse me yeah north yeah
north central north
west pennsylvania so they're in that
area as well
um the crops that they showed up in you
know got to remember all these traps
were for adults and that
may or may not tell you whether the
fruit were infested but
fall raspberries both our observations
and
observations coming in from some growers
in the region
indicate fall raspberries were
particularly the ones hit
by spotter wing in 2011
with some growers virtually having to
cease harvest and sort of close the
plants down
for the season because they just had too
much infest infestation
and were not able to get on top of it or
really didn't want to have to resort to
two or more applications of insecticide
to keep them clean
i want to show you a little data real
quickly from long island up
into october farooq head traps these
apple cider vinegar traps in
a number of crops ph apple tomato
raspberry and grapes so these are for
adults and again he had his traps out in
early mid-september
didn't catch too much then in october
really started catching a lot
and he caught that time the most in this
raspberry field where i think he was
also seen
evidence of damage in the fruit he also
caught a lot in this apple field
where they were coming from it's unclear
this was not well harvest i think there
was
apples sort of falling to the ground so
it's possible the
apples that were breaking down that were
producing a lot of flies or for
some other reason they were congregating
in this apple orchard
we don't think apples are a crop at risk
however
he did also want to point out grapes he
was vineyards out in long island
he had traps out there wasn't finding
much evidence until quite late
um but you know they're not necessarily
harvesting all their red varieties until
even into late october november and
and furu can correct me but i i believe
he had some
evidence that the fruit was being uh
infested
at that late season with some fruit
flies and some spotted wing
um i don't think he directly reared them
out but they had some evidence for that
and as i said rich
kohl's found similar things in
connecticut
to illustrate the fact this is again
data from long island
this is the percentage of spot of wing
drosophila
over time and basically the point here
in these traps is initially the
spotter wing was the minority species of
drosophila
but by the end of the season or late
season it became the dominant species
the other fruit flies are dropping out
of the system
and i think that's a common pattern and
you know i guess the real question and
fruit kept monitoring and
had even higher peaks later uh in
december or kind of astronomical
they've sure they got some freezes but
after the freezes they would still catch
a few adults and he has been catching
pretty much adults most months in
february march anyhow and in april at
low levels
so the adults are overwintering there
and as
we mentioned rich mentioned that they
are still they're catching some stuff
already in april
uh in connecticut so they're
overwintering
where they're overwintering that's a
good question we need to learn more
about that
what their survival rates important um
and sort of how they get going in that
season i think
all all important questions
in central new york real quickly uh we
also use these vinegar traps now we had
the traps out all season
so the the data from long island and
hudson valley only those traps only went
out september so okay maybe the
fruit flies were present earlier in the
season and we had traps out for the
whole season
using the vinegar traps in raspberries
cherries apples grapes and blueberries
and i had an intern working on this
project bless her heart and she
changed these traps every week through
the whole season never found
one spotted wing drosophila pretty
discouraging a couple weeks after she
went back to college
we started finding them particularly
close by
raspberry but also in some other areas
so
end of september and into october
november then we stopped trapping
we caught significant numbers of both
males and females
in the finger lakes area we had traps up
further north into
wayne county lake ontario but as we got
later in the season we stopped
we sort of stopped those traps up till
mid-september we hadn't caught anything
my guess is that some did show up later
in the season like
happened in a lot of other areas in the
northeast
okay i i want to talk a little bit about
management
and we'll go through this fairly quickly
i guess we're kind of
running out of time cultural we'll go
through cultural biological and chemical
so good sanitation is probably quite
important in a commercial field
where you're regularly picking let's say
raspberries and blueberries
uh day neutral strawberries so keeping
the level of infested
or excusing of over ripe and and ripe
fruit in the
the field down to a low level that's
unlike that's likely to help
in combination with other control
measures if you have an infestation
as i mentioned earlier maybe there's
some benefit with a big question mark on
of removing non-crop host plants or wild
hosts
in the close vicinity of the field
there's also some evidence that we need
to look at more carefully that
if you're picking fruit for market can
you
eliminate and kill off any eggs or
larvae
let's say eggs by cold storage and
there's some evidence that there's some
susceptibility to
refrigeration and we need a lot more
information on that
but that might be something for even if
you're
picking and doing roadside stands but
for retail i think you could utilize
cold storage for
uh say 24 or 48 hours to
kind of eliminate the the presence of
these insects that would be quite
helpful
biological control
what you would hope is that as this
invasive insect is here longer that some
of the native natural enemies the
parasitoids in particular
would move from other species of fruit
flies onto
spotted wing drosophila in michigan
and in in north carolina where they've
been looking at this for a number of uh
couple years anyhow they have yet to
detect any parasitism of larvae
of spotted wing by parasitoids however
in oregon
peter shear has reared out
two species of wasps from the pupae of
uh spotter wing drosophila these are i
think one of them in the family terror
malady i'm not sure the other one
i don't know how prevalent they are how
important probably
they tend to be kind of hitting the late
late in stars of this species and not at
particularly high numbers
so perhaps these species are not going
to be the important ones but maybe
others
uh will be there's also active interest
in going to the area of native uh
origin of spiderman drosophila and
looking for
natural enemies that are doing a better
job of regulating their populations
in japan and other parts of asia and
bringing those
natural enemies back united states
making sure they're not going to be at
risk for other
species in the environment and then
releasing those
as a way to control it so i guess long
term one really hopes that we see some
more
activity on the biological control stage
because partly because of
of the importance of all these wild
hosts we're never going to be able to
get out to those and
exert chemical control on it so we
really need some biological control
to help us out here so
chemical control in the short term this
is probably our main
approach to managing spotter wing
drosophila
fortunately a number of insecticides are
fairly effective targeting the adults
this is a graph of some data that rufus
collected where they
treated blueberry with different
insecticides
then exposed those things to adult
spotted wing drosophila and assessed
larvae one week week later and they
looked at a number of
compounds that we have labeled in fruit
crops
delegate and entrust our spinosa type
products immidance organophosphate
laminate say
carbamate malathones op
mustang max is a pyrethroid and peganic
is a
an organic natural pyrethroid
that can be used so of these the
spinosads
have been working quite well uh as well
as the organophosphates um
the pyrethroids also have been generally
effective so that's good we have a broad
range of insecticides some of them
fairly
narrow low risk materials like the
spinocids
that are effective peganic has not
proven particularly effective
for organic growers that's one of the
things they can resort to
and trust is another one for most of our
crops or small fruit crops
and that's been more effective although
you worry that
overuse of these things is going to
result in some resistance issues
summarizing the work of rufus and some
others
as i mentioned some of the broad
spectrum insecticides the
the ops and the pyrethroids in
particular
are effective the neonicotinoids have
not been particularly effective
the spinosans delegate in particular and
trust have been
effective materials
for new york now in new york we have
this requirement that the pest
needs to be on the label if you're going
to apply for it so we have
need for two double e label exemptions
or expansions
so new york we have a little bit more
limited uh
materials available at the moment
so that we are kind of restricted to
delegate and entrust
in canberra's bush berries um and
strawberries
um now for strawberries for uh and trust
actually we don't have that label that's
kind of a mis
mis print there there's a two double e
for
uh entrust but it didn't include
strawberries on that
i've got to check on that actually in in
strawberries we do have radiant which is
the same thing as delegate
it's effective my sense is that other
insecticides
i'm certain other insecticides will get
labeled with two double e label
uh exemptions or expansions so that
we'll
i'm sure we'll get a pyrethroid and a
carbamate
that we'll be able to use in new york
one of the key things though
for all these products is we need a very
short days to harvest
for these chemical applications which we
need to be putting on at harvest or near
harvest
so we're going to need to take that into
consideration uh
where we only can really afford one or
zero or maybe two days
to harvest in order to use them
my the upshot here is that i i think new
york and other
other areas that are ipm programs and
small fruit crops in particular which
have not been
particularly insecticide intensive in
the past
are going to be disrupted to the extent
that this
spiderwing drosophila expands and
becomes established in our area and
we're really going to have to
work hard at accommodating this problem
and looking for alternatives i do
believe monitoring right now
sort of in the year and the next years
to come is going to be important not
everybody's going to get them
they're not going to necessarily get
them at a time that's a problem so again
i want to emphasize
the importance of monitoring i'd hate to
see people just go out there and start
spraying twice a week
without really knowing they've got a
problem
and and that really brings up another
question we really want to get some
information on is you know
what is the frequency of sprees
necessary how do you decide that
as well as we need to start looking for
alternatives
speaking of alternatives i i wanted to
say that there is some interest going on
i've mentioned several of these and i
just heard today from rich coles that
a grant that he um was the lead on to
northeast ipm has just been funded to
begin looking at some of these
some of these uh alternatives and i
guess
you know in the medium term i have some
real uh optimism that we're going to
come up with some alternatives
so a couple of things we want to look at
are this idea of attracting kill
stations
and we've got a number of ideas for
things that are attractive
and looking at when we might put those
out
we've been interested in looking at this
idea of pushing
and pulling using repellents in the crop
and then putting an attractant
potentially with an insecticide
associated with it on the outside of the
crop
something that has some potential you
want to look at for some crops
richard's done some work for example
with kalyn clay and some other materials
but kaelin clay seems to be quite a
repellent
and for some crops such as grapes we may
be able to use that as a
a push and then have something whether
it's a vinegar
or one of these other attractants on the
outside of a vineyard
as a a place to get the flies to
congregate and perhaps
to kill them and keep them out of the
vineyards
so i think we're going to see a lot of
work hopefully in the in the next
few years on these alternatives so that
we're not really relying
only relying on chemical control
biological control i mentioned the
work going on in terms of international
exploration for parasitoids that
potentially could be released but this
is a very
long term prospect it takes a number of
years to identify
candidates and then to show that they're
safe to be released
uh i want to mention rich is uh doing i
think some pretty neat
uh things and wants to work with uh
entomo
fungi and bacteria bacillus
thuringiensis types bacteria
and doing some actual breeding selecting
uh experiments where he's going to look
for highly virulent
fungi or bacteria that might be used
against spotted ring drosophila in
some manner that we could take advantage
of
on that grant with rich we also wanted
to look at some ways to increase the
effectiveness of insecticides using
phagostimulants i didn't
list this here but rich has shown that
like a lot of other
flies they're stimulated by sugar and
some other things to feed and that maybe
we can combine
sugar with an a toxicant and spray it on
fields
and utilize that to enhance the efficacy
of these
insecticides and perhaps drive these
populations down to really low levels
so um there's things coming i hope that
will be helpful
in addition a number of us are on a
large um
on a grant from northeast ipm to form a
spotter wing uh drosophila working group
uh this is headed up by myself julie
cesara rodriguez sayona at rutgers and
dean polk at rutgers but a lot of people
are
going to be involved with this and our
objectives here are to
work in the northeast to identify and
prioritize research and extension needs
develop effective lines of communication
among
various groups including the growers and
facilitate uh sort of a networking with
other people and also facilitate
development of
real guidelines that we can utilize here
we will be having a winter meeting
to develop these priorities that many
people will be invited to
sometime i'm guessing now in october
and we haven't got that date figured out
but we're going to do that soon so
look forward to that and i think that'll
help us one other
major project we hope to see coming
is a project funded by the usda
especially crops program this was headed
up by hannah barack at north carolina
state but involves a number of us
in the area this would be significant
research to
develop a better understanding of the
biology of this pest
and to develop optimal control methods
now you can see the objectives there
one of the things we're very interested
in are the landscape
and production risks uh which landscapes
and
systems are most at risk for sputtering
drosophila perhaps
being able to develop uh risk management
protocols um the monitoring as i
mentioned throughout this talk is an
important one and uh cesar uh
at rutgers uh rodriguez says so anna is
uh is going to be working on that
and doing a lot uh to help develop that
we'll be working with him we also will
be working with chemical control
and best pest management uh strategies
so we should be hearing about the fate
of that grant it's a
several million dollar i think three
million dollar proposal um
probably in the next month so uh
hopefully that will come in
and if it doesn't we'll probably
resubmit for next year we feel we really
believe that
the eastern united states uh is a
critical area
and unique to western united states and
that we deserve and
warrant support from the federal
government
um finally um there are some number of
very good websites um i don't know if
i'll have time to go through all these
but and i think many of you are aware of
them i
believe the website that rufus and his
colleagues have put together at michigan
state
is quite good and worth checking out
there's even a video there
that rufus has done on monitoring that
thing's worth looking at
oregon state was one of the first to get
a website going and they have a lot of
contemporary information current
information coming up
hannah barack has got a website
including a site
that's mapping out the the discoveries
of spotted wing adults in traps
you know usually a trapping system where
people are reporting
on that i'm going to click on this real
quickly you can do that
as well i guess if you go click that
basically comes up with a map and um
that map as it will load up will show
for 2012 and previous where they're
finding
spotted wing so far in the mid-atlantic
southern southeast areas
at the moment we don't include northeast
regions but
there is plans to utilize hannah's
site to expand it up into the northeast
so that we could be reporting on this as
well
especially the early parts of invasions
early in the season and
and during colonization it might be
quite helpful to have a network of
uh stations reporting on when it's being
shown up in different areas so that if
you're a grower in an area or an
extension educating area you can be kind
of paying attention to that
and helping you be alert to potential
risk that's coming in i'm going to go
back
one other site that it's not really
worth going to now but when we meet and
develop our priorities and and get
information together
through the northeast ipm center we will
have a website
as part of their working group websites
and getting our information
and and that's where we'll post it if
that sputtering
or excuse me that scri grant the the
special crop grant comes in with hannah
one of the goals there will be to
coordinate our extension efforts
throughout the eastern united states i
don't know if you've noticed
the symbol i've been having on my slides
this is the symbol we're using with this
this group
that we're calling it e fly and uh it's
it's
sort of a symbolic of our desire to
coordinate our efforts in the eastern
united states so that we're sharing
information
sharing tools and and and uh sort of
making a coherent effort at dealing with
this problem
all right i apologize for going long i
really appreciate the questions we've
got a lot of more questions that we can
to work on but that's kind of the end of
the slides it took me a little longer
than i wanted to go through but
i just wanted to thank uh a number of
people that have contributed various
ways to
pulling this together and i guess uh
i'll let kathy direct us onto the next
steps
that's the end of our formal
presentation but we still have bunches
of questions
uh thanks all who are here you're
welcome to stay and we'll go through
those and if you need to depart
feel free to do that as well um greg we
laughed off with kate gilbert
she wanted you to give her some idea
what storm fronts
uh are what we were referring to so she
could be on the lookout for those
well yeah i'm not sure if i'm the expert
on storm fronts but
certainly things like these nor'easters
that come up
where you get this low pressure system
forming along the
the you know southern southeast or
mid-atlantic areas
and they're bringing a lot of south wind
and those south winds would be carrying
um all sorts of organisms up north and
we see this for
a number of insects and diseases for
that matter that can get transported
on these quote-unquote storm fronts so
they're low pressure systems i think
that
tend to come up from the south
donald is asking about trap action
thresholds
and then he wants to know how does
treatment schedule interact with
swd growth and development
um we do not have explicitly a trap
action threshold in the sense that you
know if you catch
fewer than five adults don't worry i
mean i think if we have anything it's if
you catch any
then at this stage especially for a
vulnerable crop if you're catching it
and you're growing fall raspberries
that says you should be probably doing
some chemical control
i mean i think that's the way we're
going to have to look at it for the time
being until we come up with some
other better information but if you've
got it just like we say for blueberry
maggot
if you get trapped catches of those
things then you initiate
almost a calendar based spray regime
until you're done harvesting i i do
believe that's probably what we're going
to have to do
for these vulnerable crops
does treatment thresholds how does it
schedule interact with spottabling
growth development i'm not sure i
understand the question
kathy do you have a uh some insights
there
i don't and maybe donald will uh
give us some direction with that in the
chat box and we'll move on to jonathan
is the pattern established in areas
where the population has
been established i was worried that they
arrived sometime mid-summer and weren't
noticed until they built into high
numbers in mid-august
well it's it's likely that
and i think connecticut would confirm
this that
they were picking up some spot of wing
prior to these storms that i mentioned
coming up
so at least in connecticut they were
probably present at low numbers
i don't know whether they were present
in you know vermont new hampshire
uh up in upstate new york
let's say in july they could have been
although we didn't catch any in our area
so it's probably a combination of both
in some regions
but the bulk i'm guessing for this last
year 2011
did come up and really didn't get going
until
late season in terms of these high
populations
um maybe a different story in 2012.
his comment is that it would be good to
survey the group and i'll put those
polls together if you want to go ahead
with carol's question
yeah to to ask in terms of folks
particularly the growers together a poll
for that if you'll go on with carol's
question
okay any suggestions for how to rear out
larvae
levon plant with a net bag no
we're yeah there is a a a protocol that
we've been using
um for rearing out and all of us rufus
in michigan state and hannah
where we collect oh let's say a hundred
grams
maybe not even that much but 100 grams
of
ripe or over ripe fruit from a couple
places let's say
five plants and we're using one of those
deli cups
on the bottom we're going to put some
sort of sponge material a small piece of
sponge and then a wire mesh
over the top of it and putting the fruit
on top of the wire mesh
as the fruit breaks down it leaks and
stuff and that liquid is collected by
the sponge
on the top we have a cover a cover on
the cup so
we used one of these 32 ounce cups and
then we have small
breathing holes in the top of the cup
but not large enough for the flies to
get out
inside the cup we're actually sticking
one of those yellow sticky cards
that when the flies pupate and emerge
out of that
fruit if they do they fly around a bit
and then get stuck on the yellow cards
and we can pull the cards out
periodically
and look at them and identify the
species of
at least identify whether they're
spotted wing drosophila
now would they come out in a mesh cage
in the field
um it's very possible you could collect
them that way as
as well long as i got air circulation
stuff i do
this problem with the the right fruit
starting to decay and fall apart
could be a problem and you need some air
circulation in there etc so i haven't
tried that
rearing in the field but my guess is we
could figure out a way to do that
it's just more convenient for us to
bring it in the lab
and put them in a either on a lab bench
or we'll use some sort of screen house
to rear them out and be able to check
them on a regular basis
okay i'm going to move on
uh farooq said uh i just wrote a comment
uh from long island that no spiderman
software emerged from rearing damaged
grapes
um uh last year however traps in the
same field did capture
uh uh some sputtering drosophila adults
so that that's something that i think
farook will hope to do
this year as we will also um up in
finger lakes is
do some rearing out of grapes just to
see when and if
they become a prob in terms of larval
infestation
gilbert gilbert says is there any
indication that this pest affects the
reproduction of wild host plants or
animal birds that eat vulnerable wild
fruits
so far it sounds like no but i wanted to
check
yeah so um
in terms of affecting their reproductive
success no evidence that i know of that
the fruit is damaged to the extent that
um you know not enough viable seeds are
produced etc
i suppose that's a risk although i agree
i doubt that's going to be a
huge problem you know whether it'll
affect dispersal
my guess is this flies will be
if birds get it might they might get
consumed i'm assuming that the flies
would die if they got
eaten but if they were dropped by
foraging birds and things like that it
would probably not
bother them um i don't think you know i
think it'd just be a little extra
protein in terms of the fruits consuming
it
but yeah i i would guess no
in terms of a big uh impact on the on
the
success of these native plants although
you know i guess i wouldn't completely
rule it out it's an interesting question
bernie smith asks hate to spray when
fruit is ripe what should suggest for
organic sprays yeah boy
i guess for organic sprays right now
unless we can come up with some of these
attracting kill stations and things of
that that can work and i really want to
test those and i think rich would agree
with me we want to test some of these
ideas
chemical control now we do have what is
a quite effective material for chemical
control but it's expensive
so let's suppose you're doing uh fall
raspberries
you're sort of gotten into harvest and
you find that you're seeing some
spottoing drosophila
and trust is a good material
that could be put on i i forget the
label restrictions though there is
some restrictions on how much you can
use so that becomes a
somewhat of an issue and the expense
they're very expensive
i i wish at least right now i don't have
a great alternative
i think it would help though to be as
much as possible keeping the right fruit
regularly picked and and out of the
field
i hope to have some of this this cold
storage information i hope we get some
data on that in the short term
and that might be another approach but
i guess i don't have a any great
great uh answers for organic growers
right now
ra other than and trust and frankly
we're lucky that we have a material as
good as and trust some of our organic
products
like paganic for spotted wing are not
particularly good and they're expensive
so it's kind of a double whammy i think
in trust
although expensive is is quite effective
so we at least have something
we can utilize but i i
sympathize it's it is something that
we're not
used to having to do in any of the small
fruits especially uh
the northern areas and northeast in
terms of spraying insecticides and
particularly organic growers have been
able to get through without having to
spray a lot
and this is maybe a game changer it may
not but i think there's that risk
um eric asks given that we certainly
uh we will certainly be inadvertently
breeding uh
drosophila suzukii for resistance
organophosphates spinosads pyrethines is
there any prospect that given its
similarity to a well-studied model
organism that we could be
deliberately breed for traits like
smaller oapaws or life cycle timing or
chemical cue preferences
yes and no indeed they are easy to rear
pretty easy to rear in the lab
they can get contaminated with more
hearty species but
you can breed them you could do genetics
on it and you're right
we know the genome of drosophila
melanogaster
and that might provide us insights you
know
i don't know about i can't imagine
something like smaller ovipauser
although you imagine you could breed
something like that potentially
uh through radiation and all sorts of
things
once you release it i can't imagine that
fly would be successful and replace the
other one
you raised some really interesting
questions about genetic
mechanisms for introducing
deleterious traits into populations and
there is a lot of work going on let's
say for
malaria mosquitoes and yes
long term that would be a pretty
interesting area to pursue i think
i think it's a really interesting idea
of using some sort of
positive feedback systems that they've
worked out in terms of genetic models
to do that under population genetics
field conditions
and drive in a deleterious trait
into a population like of an invasive
species
i mean there's some risk associated with
that but i think it's kind of an
interesting and exciting area of pursuit
so i
nothing short term though i i see there
however knowing that the genetics of it
may provide us
other avenues such as using
something called rnai technology
identifying
protein products that are important for
the fruit fly
to survive and then interfering with
that uh through either getting into the
plant
or spraying it on and using that to
very target in a targeted way kill this
insect and i think there's some real
potential there and having
knowledge of the genetics of
our melanogastar is going to promote
that and i know a
number of people are looking at that so
that that's some pretty interesting
ideas
okay if we drop down to bernie smith
he's
asking then when would you suggest
praying for a blueberry farm
between july 1 and september 15.
well it maybe depend partly where that
blueberry farm is
and i guess i would suggest monitoring
starting in july first um
and i guess
i would be happier if you were
rigorous about the traps maybe changing
the traps more than once a week looking
for adults and then
spraying when you actually detect the
adults if you're very conservative and
very worried yeah i mean i guess i don't
have enough experience to know
um my my guess based on what we've seen
this year and again depending on where
you're at
um we really didn't start seeing things
uh
spiking until um september so i guess i
i
wouldn't just jump on starting sprays
until late august kind of thing
i'm hopeful at least for this year we're
going to be safe but i'd also say
let's let's pay attention to our
extension uh
messages coming out for your region and
and more locally
we'll have these websites and we'll have
email alerts coming out
and and also take advantage of that so
if you have a neighbor that's starting
to catch them
or someone not too far away that can
also be some information that you can
use to go into
a decision like that i hope that that
helps somewhat
dropping down richard cowell's has a
comment
okay he's saying three to three quarters
to two pounds of sugar per hundred
gallons will greatly enhance the
activity of spinosan-based insecticides
thank you richard
and i don't know richard you're still
with us and can comment i i believe
that's
based on a lot of your lab work i don't
know if you've had a chance to
to try that under the field conditions
but i know that you have a pretty
striking
results in the lab and it's like like
like i said this
i guess we have plans to try this out
under field conditions this year
and k gilbert is again talking about
storm fronts
the flies literally get blown up here
and richard comments down below
the best information we have is from new
hampshire
spotted wing drosophila did not arrive
until after tropical storm irene
okay on to jonathan bishop uh following
up now
following up now that they are here
should we be worried about earlier
season crops
since we've already observed them
well yeah i think there is a slight
trend towards these flies showing up a
little earlier each year in areas let's
say michigan north carolina where
they've had them for a couple years
so and as i mentioned earlier we have
now some evidence at least a few maggots
in june bearing strawberries at the end
of the season in a field that
was you know not picked particularly
clean
so yeah i think we we let's say summer
raspberries
and or earlier maturing blueberries i do
think we need to be paying attention to
that my best guess is
least for the time being it's the late
season stuff that's the most vulnerable
but yeah absolutely we
unless there's some crazy thing and that
a hard winter next winter just wipes
them all out in the northeast
uh i do think this is something we're
gonna have to live with and figure out
um how to deal with um
we shall see but yeah that's my best
guess is that this is something that's
going to be here to stay
um okay and
oh richard responded to your inquiry
saying he's only
he's just used it in the lab but he had
great data
yep and while we're waiting to see if
there any other questions the results of
the polls are there i just wanted to
point out to people
of the 16 people who responded seven
have had spotted wing drosophila in
their planting
and if you look down below uh there was
one detection in march
but the others uh began in july
and then with the highest number in
august and then also in september
interesting no that's that's nice
interesting and farouk said just to
clarify the poll data
we see spider-wing drosophila and traps
in the last week of march that was this
year 2012.
okay
any other questions or comments i just
while we're finishing i just want to let
you know i'll be sending you all an
email with a link
to the recorded version so you'll be
able to listen to it again later if
you'd like to
i'll also include the links to the
webinar to the
resources that dr loeb gave us in that
slide just at the end
and thank you so much for joining us
we'll be here a couple more minutes to
see if there are any more questions
thank you greg for your presentation it
was very good welcome
thanks for all the comments and
questions everyone that was uh great i
think we had a good exchange and
plenty to do
thank you kathy for getting this
organized that was uh well done we had
to fight a little bit this morning but
not you and me but fight with our
equipment but uh
yeah i'm really glad i think it worked
out very well and you're
you're welcome to keep the headset oh
well well nice a present thank you
okay there doesn't appear to be any
other burning questions
we'll take all your suggestions into
consideration
and we thank you for being with us this
afternoon and have a great weekend
all right see everyone bye thanks thanks
kathy see ya bye thanks